I'm excited to drink some hot chunky goo
little nauseous cuz it all kind of look
like an animal had diarrhea this smells
like almond joy I think this is coconut
all right it's coconut e nouns I kind of
like mounds better as a drink number two
this looks awful a lot of crunch either
that or her like boiled beetles
exceptionally chunky mmm I'm not excited
about my so so is this beautiful of
mostly soggy being that I was gonna go
say Snickers Snickers sighs that may
hold peanuts in it this one looks huge
there's almost no smell which is really
alarming move on donkey what is in here
oh my god there's something frothy about
it's almost like a gross poop lot X like
a marshmallow I think will you clean up
your garbage disposal that one leaves a
really strong mouth coating I'm gonna
say Three Musketeers
uh Three Musketeers has just been shitty
Milky Way there I said it a very proud
of myself for this are their noodles in
this there's literally pasta snakes of
caramel seems like more gelatinous I
can't even pick it up with my spoon the
consistency of steak fat like anything
about that so I'm just trying to think
of a candy bar that has tasteless
fettuccine strips in it ooh what are you
I don't know what you are wait a minute
I have an idea the wafer becomes a
sponge in the worst way I feel like $15
for this at a restaurant
Oh what what the [ __ ] are you what's
living at the bottom of this oh my god
there's a big beam here I don't know if
I want to taste this this looks like a
someone's organ room exactly what a
twelve-year-old boy wants after having a
snowball fight
that was perfect like that straight up
look like those little monster figurines
in on Ernest scared stupid I think this
is the first time we ever get to
reference an Ernest film and it tastes
as but I'm thrilled about it this has
truly been a terrible experience